hey folks and welcome to gamespot
cyberpunk 2077
full spoilercast i'm lucy joined by cali
hello
and jake hello now it should be pretty
obvious but this
is going to be a com like filled with
spoilers
we're going to be dissecting the story
so if you haven't completed the game
this is your chance to back away now and
another piece of housekeeping
uh there is obviously a lot going on
with cyberpunk right now
crunch issues last-gen console issues
next-gen upgrade issues the whole kit
and caboodle
we're not going to be touching upon that
in this video because this video is just
our spoiler cast of the story however if
you do want to be kept up to date
with everything going on in cyberpunk
make sure to like this video and
subscribe
to our channel so you'll be first in
line when we upload something new
we're going to be covering a lot of
ground in this video so we have got
timestamps in the description
for your convenience all right let's get
[Music]
going
[Music]
let's start off with overall impressions
now kelly you did
our review gave it a seven out of ten uh
can we quickly distill your feelings on
the game now that you've had some time
to reflect on it a bit more yeah um i
should say it was kind of like a
a soft seven when i went in i um kind of
waffle between a six and a seven i would
say like as
time has gone on i've i've kind of um
my opinion has diminished a little bit
so i would say some highlights for me
were the side stories i thought
the side quests were really strong in a
lot of ways there was a lot of variety
in the side quests
maybe not as complex in terms of like
what you were actually doing
but um a lot of interesting kind of like
light the match of an idea i'm gonna
follow this thread
um i really liked the core cast of
characters um
and that that also kind of fed into what
i didn't like so much about the game
because i felt like
so many of those things like they were
explored up until a point
and then kind of dropped which we'll
definitely talk about in this video
um in more detail um and i really think
like i i wish
that the game had more to say i feel
like it brought up all these really
interesting ideas and
i really started out like really
intrigued and
then a lot of those threads just kind of
dissipated
i also think it it kind of suffers as an
rpg
i think that there is some cool variety
to the
combat and like to the way you can
approach different things like with
hacking
or with different cybernetics but um
i felt like i was playing a canon
character rather than role playing my
own character
um i think that's just something that
you fall into when you have a voiced
playable character it it just seemed to
me like
trying to be the best of both worlds a
written character
and your own character i just don't
think that worked very well
i agree with a lot of what you said
actually i
really really enjoyed my time with the
game i
like there was a lot of it that i really
really liked and then there was some
stuff that just upon reflection and
having completed it a week or so ago now
that i'm thinking back and going like
yeah that wasn't maybe the best thought
out
i think we did a video uh jake john luke
and i last week and it was about
which you can watch we'll link to it
down below but it was a list of things
that we would love to see improved
and actually when we were brainstorming
for that list there was a lot of things
especially quality of life updates that
i would i would absolutely love to see
added to the game because
it does just kind of chip away at the
good
times i guess there were some real
standout moments for me uh we'll
definitely talk about side quests and
some of the characters
judy my love pan am river i loved love
loved those quests and i think
it was at its best when it was really
really claustrophobic like in that first
opening mission for example if you play
corpo where it's super tense and you're
kind of
or at least the heist in uh when you're
in the hotel when it's these really
tense moments
i think it really really shines but i
think it definitely loses some of its
luster in the open world
i just felt like there was too much in
there and not enough of it
interested me uh but jake what what
about you what did you think
my thoughts on this game have been a
roller coaster
i would initially when i initially
played it which was over a very short
period like cali a couple days
i really enjoyed it uh i think as more
people got their hands on it a lot of
the
bug discourse started happening people
started poking holes through different
things
i kind of lost interest and kind of
started getting a little disappointed
but i've been replaying it slowly
on a second playthrough and i've really
been enjoying it honestly i've been
having i've been having a great time
uh that said a lot of what you guys have
said i
entirely agree with i think there are a
lot of issues
with the story clashing with the
gameplay
there are a lot of issues with the rpg
elements i think i don't think a lot of
them
work as well as they hoped but there are
things there that i
really do genuinely like i think for
example like
we don't want to talk too much about the
gameplay but i think the gameplay works
really well the later on you get
uh and like the way certain things can
just completely change
how you play something simple like the
double jump like
like genuinely changed how i was playing
that game like there'd be
objectives or there'd be small missions
i'd do where normally i'd just go
through the front door or try to sneak
in where i could just
literally jump to the roof drop in grab
what i needed
needed to get and leave and that stuff
is super cool those gameplay decisions
that they give
you i think are excellent it's just
how the gameplay manifests itself in the
story that just
doesn't quite work with me but that
being said overall i was
i i i was and i am still pretty positive
on the game i'm super excited to see
how they update this game uh how they
fix things add new features
and of course dlc like i think there's
still so many more stories to tell in
night city
i love the way you danced around saying
ludonarrative disease
absolutely made you put five dollars in
a jar for that one
all right let's let's start off at the
beginning like at the beginning of the
game which life path
did we all pick cali which one did you
go for um i went with nomad i just
figured you know
i don't know anything about night city
besides what i knew about the tabletop
game
um so i'll go with the character that
doesn't know a lot about night city
jake uh i did nomad for the first
playthrough street kid
on the second playthrough and i think
this is one of my big bigger issues with
the game
is that that doesn't really manifest
into a lot
and i'm sure we'll touch on that but
that's something that i did want to
mention
i even replayed the nomad one recently
with rob for a gameplay series we're
working on
and they set up characters that you
never meet
that have nothing to do with the story
and it just feels like something just
got cut from the game
that was a long-winded way to say yeah i
played nomads but
i wanted to get that out of my system
well no so that's interesting so i
played corpo
and because i loved the idea of you know
being in the heart of a mega corp and
taking it down from the inside
um because in my head at least i had it
all planned out that i was gonna be you
know this
corporate runner who's been wronged and
you know i
that definitely speaks to cali what you
were saying where it's like so many
ideas that just don't quite
you know there was so much promise and
it just doesn't quite hit those threads
um
we don't need to get into that too much
just now but my
uh in my corporate playthrough when i
was arriving in the arasaka building
there is a character
who you can choose to speak to and
he only really stuck out for me because
he reminded me a lot of kendall from
succession
just like this very awkward corporate
man and
he also sounded a little bit like him
and i did actually encounter him later
on in the game which i was very
surprised at
and he tried to like mess me
mess me around or you know when you're
when you start the corporal life path
there is this incident happening at
arasaka
and he has all this info on it and he
tries to basically say to you hey i have
this info for you
you can get one over on arasaka and i
met him and it was the most
just it wasn't it just didn't really
have any repercussions i met up with him
and he immediately just tried to attack
me so i killed him
and that was it it just didn't amount to
anything i thought it was going to be
this big sweeping choice that i'd made
that would come back
later but it wasn't um was it was it a
side quest
yeah i think he just like texted me
and said hey i have this info and johnny
was obviously unhappy because it was oh
you're still a corpo [ __ ]
kind of thing cause that is something i
do want to say just to cover our bases
here is that there are specific
quests that you can get depending on the
life path you choose
but most of them i don't think any of
them really have anything to do with the
overall story
that being said i haven't finished
street kid i haven't done corpo
but based on your experience it doesn't
sound like that happens the street
the the nomad doesn't that doesn't
happen and with street kid i've started
the quest
that is specific to street kid so i
don't know if that ties in
but based on our experiences it seems
like
these special quests depending on your
life path don't really factor into
the main story yeah how did you feel
about the language though like the
the specific uh text options you could
pick
um i mean it didn't really seem to alter
anything too much for me i did like
um having the nomad options with pan am
um
i thought that like gave a little bit
more dimension to
her specifically but um
i didn't like it didn't overall
shape the way i approached anything or
give me like new insight that you know
comparing notes of people who played
other life paths that like
i don't think i got anything different
out of it than you did
yeah it seemed more flavor to me and i i
didn't mind it i
did like it especially like you're
saying with pan am and now that i'm
playing a street kid like
i know my way around rogue a bit more
than i would otherwise and i think
all those details are really nice
additions
but uh yeah it didn't like fundamentally
change the way i was talking to
characters and interacting with the
world
i felt like maybe maybe because i picked
corpo
and obviously all the dealings you have
with arasaka i thought there were some
really nice
flourishes to using those voice lines um
when you're
going and the thing is i haven't really
i did the
nomad live path intro just to capture it
but i didn't play any more beyond that
but you know when you go to the hotel on
that heist
you know you can be a dick to the um the
person on reception
and there are other things like when
you're with takamura you can reference
your old corporate life because you have
that kind of shared backstory
so even if it didn't impact it too much
i did really like the flavor
yeah absolutely flourish that's a good
that's a good way of putting it
uh okay we've danced around uh side
missions before we talk about how we
felt
the overall main story quest uh panned
out but let's talk about side missions
because
cali you mentioned this before we've all
talked about this before the some of
those have really been
the standouts um let's talk about
cinnamon let's talk about cinnamon
which where do you even begin with that
one
i think it says a lot when the game
actively blocks you from taking
any screenshots of a particular side
mission yeah oh i guess for setup for
those who maybe don't care and are
watching this video
sooner man is basically you meet a
character who
thinks of himself as the second coming
of jesus christ and
he wants to get crucified while the
brain dance is being recorded
so other people can experience the
suffering that
jesus went through there's more to it
than that but that's like
that's the elevator pitch you
experienced that
crucifixion you can even partake in it
by nailing
his appendages into the cross which is
what i did
uh matt padgett walked away uh he's just
no
i'm not gonna do this and walked out the
door and finished the quest and i was
like
that i don't blame you i don't blame you
yeah
i that quest is interesting because
you're kind of egged on to it by um
johnny like johnny will be like if you
don't
do this i will never forgive you this is
the first interesting thing that's ever
happened to us
and i'm like okay man so i followed it
just kind of at his
um insistence and then i ended up
crucifying a man
so i mean he wasn't wrong
it is the most interesting thing that
happened um
it felt like really it was interesting
because um you walk around the
city and you can see these like
uh posters for like basically the
passion um
and it's kind of just that's what this
is it's like tying into those
advertisements you see which
you don't get a ton of in this game so i
really appreciated that like those
uh ads that you're seeing for this like
it's just jesus's head i think um
actually came into play somewhere but i
was not expecting
to have to physically nail the person to
the cross and then just walk out you
just have to walk out
and be like okay that i guess i'll just
go on with my day
then and it's the fact that you have the
producer you know like the thing about
that quest as well is that i think it's
a
i think it's a standout quest and i
think it was really good
good seems like a weird word to use
because of the subject matter but i
think
overall on reflection of it it had a lot
more to say than a lot of other yeah
cyberpunk did there are so many elements
to it you know like this man on death
row
killed someone so you go and meet the
victim's family
um you go and you have the producer
who's also egging you on and being like
why why do you have to ruin this for all
of us is it gonna make so much money
this is what he wants
you try and talk him out of it i was
unsuccessful i'm not even sure if you
can talk him out of it
and then yeah you have that moment where
you just slowly watch him die
as he's being recorded and all the
casting crew around him just don't seem
to care
and it is very very interesting and very
thought-provoking
but it was just one of those ones where
there weren't as many i think that stood
out as much as that one did
and i'm still processing my catholic
guilt about it
yeah i think that was one like that
question in particular really stood out
to me for many reasons but i think one
of the big things is that we just don't
really see
quests like that in triple a games right
yeah like
i mean assassin's creed for example came
out a month before
and you'd think that that would have a
lot to do with uh
with catholicism christianity because it
takes place as the vikings enter
england and maybe that stuff is there to
some extent to be completely transparent
i haven't finished it
but the way that's written in cyberpunk
2077 feels a lot more
daring um to an extent in
in that regard i really do like that
quest and i really do like the writing
in cyberpunk 2077.
uh i just kind of wish there was more
of that especially in this world that is
supposed to be really
affronting and kind of like an assault
to the senses yeah i
i want to talk about um the perales
quest as well a little bit so you kind
of get it by
um interacting with river for the first
time it's also what sets off river's
quest but i thought the paralysis quest
was
really really cool talking about
manipulating
uh politicians by by by rewiring them
essentially and all this constant
surveillance and i thought that was
really really cool and then
to cali's point earlier it was a great
thread that just went nowhere
and then depending on what you do i
assume daniel perales
rang me at the end because i told him
that his wife was in on it
yeah i did too yeah he just he just
vanished
uh i couldn't text him or call him
anymore i couldn't text or call the wife
anymore
and that was it and there was no that i
found
there was no repercussion really beyond
that yeah and
that quest is so interesting i mean it's
it's basically about gaslighting in a
way that like
is impossible now like it's it's just
reframing what gaslighting means
um and these people are literally being
made to feel crazy
or and their memories are being altered
in a way that's like honestly terrifying
to me and i found it so compelling and
you
it's like this cool investigative
sequence where you're like going through
the apartment and trying to find clues
and then
you discover that something's fishy and
like there's so much to that and
and then you know i wanted to know like
who's doing this to them
what is the source of this and like
that's the part that was missing from
that and i was just so expecting it to
be
taken a little further on the the other
side like
um a quest that also was intriguing and
i thought was like
so interesting from the very beginning
but then like
just absolutely crushed me was the
bartmost collective quest where
um it starts with nancy so i kind of did
it late in the game
and you know to
the game's credit like i was at the
point where i was like i really need to
finish this game for the review so i was
like not in the mood to waste my time
um and this quest definitely wasted my
time so that probably made me dislike it
even more
but it's like you're seeing this um
website
that's just basically a kind of a
caricature of
socialists um who are rejecting
the way night city is and the corruption
night city and the quest is like
finding the per person who the
originator of this
like radical content and i was really
interested in this because
i thought it would be so cool to see
what the
rejection of commercialism and
capitalism in the city would look like
and the quest is just going from place
to
place finding a wi-fi router and then
it takes you to another place with
another wi-fi router until you reach
a sign of like a fortune teller and it's
just been a whole it's just been a prank
the whole time
and the thing that was i was like almost
insulted by that i was like
so is there nobody in this city who's
rejecting who's like actively trying to
fight back against
this system first of all i wouldn't i
don't believe that would be that would
be the case at all
and second of all like i was really
hoping to see
like some sort of mirror to look into
the world and kind of evaluate how do i
feel about
night city through this this lens of
this group
and to find out it was just like
somebody pranking it just felt like like
the game was mocking me almost for
taking an interest in it
um i just that was like the worst quest
by far for me
yeah i mean i think i'm amazed that that
quest
was in this game and didn't get cut
because especially coming off the
witcher where all the quests even the
monster hunts just feels so impactful
and purposeful
they're all they all tell their own
unique stories and this one was just a
blatant waste of time
like even if you take out like like the
context of it
and and it could be about anything
and it would still be a waste of time
because the actual act of the mission
is just driving to all corners of night
city only to get to the end and johnny's
like oh yeah it was just a
program that has been bounced around the
city for a while
and it's just like wait what like
there's nothing to like
it's like when you take the most obvious
twist and you go with
that and then you expect people to be
surprised by the twist but it's just
like
no there's no reward to this there's
nothing rewarding or interesting about
it
yeah i didn't care for that one either
to be honest i thought
i i definitely got to the point of no
return and
just went backwards and just kind of
completed all the side quests that i was
interested in and i
i went for that one because i thought i
would get
something something i'd learned
something and ultimately when it was
just the uh
the fortune teller robot thing i was
like oh okay
that was the point for me where i was
like i'm just gonna finish this bit and
yeah like that deliberately felt like
the game was wasting my time
let's talk about uh who did you guys
romance
judy i feel like we've all done the same
yes
i mean technically i did judy and river
and a few side characters because
originally we were going to
put a video up of all the all the sex
scenes but we decided not to because
they're all very awkward and
kind of explicit uh so i saw a lot of
them and they're all very awkward but
yeah judy was
my the one my canon one
me too i i also had a one night stand
with river
me too and felt like such an [ __ ]
the morning after because i i thought
the way that you can handle that and
tell him
that well i do and i don't love the way
that you can tell the characters that
you're dying
because it just seems like they don't
really take it seriously
yeah at all like the way i talk i told
river i was like
hey i don't think we should get into a
thing because i'm actually not
not long left for this world and he was
like oh yeah no
okay i understand i like what
that's how you react to that and judy
was actually
pretty similar which
i love judy but i was like what if i
need a shoulder to cry on here
yeah yeah the like everything in this
game i just feel like
it starts out pretty strong and then
fizzles out so
with river i did the scene to see what
it looked like and
i hated it so much i actually rolled
back my save and rejected him
oh that's the one that's the one you did
that followed
yeah i uh did not care for that scene at
all
um i i like withered and died
watching that
i don't know there was just something
about it there's just something about it
um
and i also felt bad because i was like
i'm cheating on judy i'm already in love
with judy
so uh the judy one though like judy's
quest i think
is like the standout for me in terms of
i mean like at every step of the way
that last sequence where you
dive in her hometown um was like
like impeccable i am obsessed with that
quest i wish i had saved right before so
i could like just do it over and over
again
um but yeah then like it's like she
gives you access to her apartment
and then i'm like so are we are we
getting that u-haul we moving in
together and then
um and then like
yeah the you talk about i have some
stuff going on and then it's like oh
like
it just feels later it just it feels
like it doesn't um
really get there and i don't want to
jump the gun but we'll talk about how
that factors into the endings as well
which i think only
um exacerbates that issue for me but i
do think like
one thing i want to note is that from
what i can tell i don't think the actual
scenes
change depending on if you're
romantically
available to them so the characters
basically have set sexualities
um there are four of them basically
to simplify it like a gay male straight
male gay female straight female
um but i don't think they change how
they
act like i think the scenes are
identical aside from the actual romantic
part so like pan am
was so flirty that i was absolutely
blown away that she was straight i was
like there's no way this woman is
straight she's like
i put my hand in her leg and she was
like yeah she was like oh you're giving
me that
i think even if you are a male and you
follow through river's quest you still
end up going to his family barbecue and
whatnot and i think i saw some people
react to it on stream and they were like
wait am i
is he going to try to date me what's
going on yeah which
is like it's interesting because it's
like the choice to then make them
have a set sexuality it's really
interesting because like why then
if the scenes aren't going to be
different one thing i do want to mention
about river though is his side quest
where
you hunt down that killer that's that
was so cool and i want a game of that
yeah where you're like you're like
revisiting a serial killer's memories
and i think that is super interesting
and that's something that i was i don't
know about if i was hoping to see more
of that serial killer but i was hoping
to do more like
detective work based on yeah uh
brain dance and stuff because it is such
a neat idea that
they do some really cool things with but
i don't feel like they do enough
with it particularly too when it comes
to just like entertainment value
right like yeah like i think it would be
really interesting to just buy like
a brain dance that was just i don't know
one of the one of the stars of the world
one of the suit like
what is there lizzy wizzy's brain dance
to like just experience
things as her for a little bit just to
see what that's like because that is a
big part of
cyberpunk how brain dances are
entertainment but i feel like they were
always a utility
well do i have the game for you batman
arkham origin
i gotta play that yeah i
i loved rivers side quest i think that
for me was the standout and maybe it's
because i have
a heightened interest in true crime uh
the
the judy one got soured for me because i
did half of it and then i left to go do
something and i turned off my
playstation
and it made me restart the whole thing
so i was like
okay it didn't auto save so i literally
got all the way up to the church and
then had to redo that whole thing again
oh my god that's good uh but rivers
rivers i really loved i loved pan ams
too
i thought that the scorpion tank thing
whatever that was i don't understand
i didn't care for it i just felt like
maybe someone on the art and weapons
team was like hey what if we had a big
tank you know why don't we just have why
don't we just have a big tank and then
obviously the way that it comes in
um all the time uh
just to play around with us like it
didn't feel particularly good i would
have preferred just to be you know in
pan am's a truck and just shooting
using that again but if you sleep with
her you sleep with her in the tank
so oh that tank also does come into play
if you get there if you get help from
the nomads too
i did it let's see i did do that ending
as well and i was like
i still don't love the tank i think we
should talk about johnny silverhand
though
okay for characters before we move on to
endings because
he is the main character of this game
more or less yeah
uh and i thought he was fantastic
i really and like you mentioned this too
cali and it is like
partly sheer star power of keanu reeves
but just having keanu reeves with you
the entire time was
was was really cool and i really liked
what he added to these different quests
i think he adds a lot of flavor to what
may seem mundane like especially some of
the really simple side quests that
are just kind of like go here kill these
guys grab this thing and leave
at least johnny kind of sets it up and
he
throws some insults makes fun of you a
little bit and then like gives you the
details
and kind of sets you on your way and
just like how intertwined he is
he intertwined he is with everything i
think just like
bumps up everything in my book just just
slightly
yeah absolutely i agree with that
because like he really does provide a
lot of color even
the way the shots are staged like
there's a lot of conversations and
that's actually something i really liked
about cyberpunk
in general as a quick aside like a lot
of the missions are just like talking to
somebody
um which i think is really cool i liked
that it wasn't necessarily like i have
to do combat to um
get some story information and the way
those conversations are framed often has
like johnny in the background like doing
something
being kind of sassy like lounging
looking bored
uh shaking his head smoking a cigarette
you know whatever it is
and i thought that was so well done and
i i found that to be
one of the highlights for me and i also
said in my review like
johnny i johnny on paper like i should
hate him johnny silver
silver hand is such an [ __ ] he like
treated
women terribly when he was alive he's
kind he kind of says some sexist things
to you if you play as a female v
like he mentions like being in your body
um
and i did not hate him i thought i
i was like oh what a lovable [ __ ]
like yes
like i i think that that's a testament
to keanu reeves performance like i think
he really sells the character
in a way that could have gone very
poorly um and just
been kind of like could have just
grossed me out because he has a lot of
issues but um yeah keanu reeves like
the line delivery like god i
i really loved the the johnny silverhand
stuff i think the game really picks up
when you get him
in your head the way you unravel his
story too and like the way his motives
change and the way he changes over the
course i think
are all pretty good like i was telling
callie the first time i played it
that mission tapeworm which is after you
do the voodoo boy stuff you walk out and
have a conversation with johnny
you can just shut him up right away you
can just take the psycho
something to dream i don't remember what
it's called and stop him and that's what
i did the first time because he was
being a dick and i was like
all right i've had enough dude and i
actually like let him
play it out on my second flight there
and i like was
genuinely impressed with the line the
writing the delivery and all that stuff
was
was just it was very powerful i just
like felt empowered i was like yeah
yeah let's burn arasaka down let's go
i yeah i loved him i just felt like
he was a reassuring presence in a sort
of way
you being you know as a player you are
new to night city
like depending on what life path you
pick you're expected to know it
and he just provides all of this context
and
sometimes he pushes you in the right
direction sometimes he tries to push in
the wrong direction
but he will you know if you do something
that he doesn't agree with
he'll make his opinion known but you
don't feel like penalized for doing it
really
i just i really loved the way he was
integrated in it so let's use that as a
jumping off point to actually talk about
the
the story as a whole i thought
i don't know because i i obviously kind
of did it in weird chunks
i would i did like the first act with
pretty much no side missions
and then i did the second act and pretty
much almost mainlined the story
up until maybe even the um
the parade and aft just before i did the
parade that's when i branched out and
did all of my
side quest stuff and then i kind of
obviously mainlined
the the final act overall i really
enjoyed it
i think that there are some bits that
shine more than others i think
when like i said earlier when things get
really really tense
like the original like the heist
uh in the hotel i also think when you
i mean i know johnny's stuff and rogue
stuff is like side content but in my
head it makes more sense of them if
their main story but i really loved
building those relationships with those
two and kind of understanding the past
more to
kind of push forward in the future i
think
the parade mission with takamura was
really really cool and i think i was
playing on ps5
um i'm in the middle of rebuilding a pc
i think if i was playing that on a pc
it would just absolutely blow me away
because that
just looked incredible and that scene
was a spectacle
yeah it's beautiful that was one of my
favorite parts of the game
partly because of how beautiful it
looked but also just
how intricate that area was designed and
how you work your way through the
different stories and you take out
snipers
and then you get up to that fight which
was kind of broken for some people from
what it sounds like but for me it was
it was pretty fun he was stuck in a
corner
and uh i was hiding behind a pillar and
i would just pop out and use my rocket
wrist
thing grenade thing just chip it away at
him and he couldn't hit me so that fight
was completely broken for me
but i still enjoyed that mission it's a
shame i thought that fight was very good
yeah overall i really liked it but i was
not happy with the ending that i got
because
this doesn't make any damn sense to me
it didn't make any sense like
i was building my v up to be
you know she was a corporate rat she
left that life behind
she had this friend in jackie and i
absolutely loved jackie i
loved that you felt like you actually
had this buddy
going like working with you to become a
legend
and then the way that jackie dies
i could see coming but it was still a
real blow for me and i think
that it was really good that that's when
you get you you don't have long to kind
of spend by yourself you get johnny to
kind of fill the void of someone to kind
of go through this adventure with
but i would have loved to spend more
time with jackie i think for me
that was one of the biggest
disappointments is that jackie just
like i thought they built such a great
character with jackie and they kill them
off pretty quickly and what was even
weirder is that they even showed that
off in marketing
so i assumed they were doing like a
one-two switch one two switch i don't
know where that came from
doing like a a fake out or maybe like
maybe it was like
yeah maybe it was like depending on your
choices he might actually live but he
dies no matter what
which i i think is kind of a big bummer
because
like i feel like the ev i don't know i
don't speculate too much but
i feel like there was just a hole
missing throughout
that game by not having anyone you had
any real connection with
apart from johnny because he was in your
head
yeah yeah it almost feels like
like that section just doesn't last very
long and part of that was that i did
mainline act one um
i didn't do a lot of side stuff because
i had seen in the marketing that jackie
died so i like knew
that that that was coming and i was like
assuming that would come pretty quickly
but it also feels like you could have
used a little bit more time if you
wanted that death to
really be impactful um just a little
more time maybe one or two more like
missions with him to bond
although i will say the funeral really
got me
like i i i did really like his character
and
the funeral like as was actually
emotional for me and i
kind of was like i don't know where this
emotion is coming from
um but i found it really touching uh i
will say and i
i talked about this in my review a
little bit that uh calling it no frienda
was really weird to me because
that refers to the altar specifically
and it is usually
at altar iv day of the dead and i think
they were using the word
ofrenda to mean funeral
so i found the the thing a little
confusing but the actual scene was
really touching
yeah and i think going around his place
with misty in particular was
very like really got me um
but overall like i loved the stuff with
evelyn because i thought that's where it
got really interesting for me
like going and um obviously you can do
more
stuff and um what's it called clouds
yeah this guy
with um judy if you do her side stuff
i thought it was really cool but then
the ending
um so i got the ending where i decided
to let johnny have my body picked up
rogue rogue
i absolutely adore i think yeah i
thought she i thought she was a great
character and i loved it
that voice actor is really good too yeah
just has like such an incredible voice
we all pay a price for the choices we
make i'm no exception
she commands a lot of presents and i
think she was really well cast and she's
a bad [ __ ]
she's a bad [ __ ] and she looks
fantastic and i want to age like rogue
me too she you know taking taking rogue
and going up with the arasaka
the johnny uh not the johnny the uh adam
smasher fight
was fine it's fine it's like a standard
end of game
boss fight not if it breaks for you
multiple times
none of it breaks you multiple times but
then it was the
plugging into the
the system where i got
a little confused because obviously
you've got alts and you've already
you've set up what you're gonna do with
all and then you go in it's like okay
well here are your choices
and so i went well johnny we had a good
run
uh you know we're birds now i made sure
that johnny
uh his approval of me was high and uh he
was like i'll go
you stay so i went back to the real
world but it made me feel
like i wasn't doing that i had to sort
of double check because the wording on
it was super weird
and i i was like okay i went back and i
wake up in this glorious apartment and
i'm with judy i'm like hey everything
everything turned out okay
and then judy's like well i'm leaving
and then you just eat yourself into
space
and then you eat yourself into space
because you're the head of the afterlife
and it's like callie was saying
i don't know how i got there how did i
get out of arasaka
that's the thing i we did the same
ending just coincidentally
and i i was just like wow i would have
loved to have been there
to see these things happen um
and then i look like a complete idiot
because my v
looks like an idiot yeah and so i didn't
need
that switch to third person yeah i was
really i was like i would have loved to
change my hairstyle
um and then the thing that really got me
is that like judy was the person i had
made a connection with
in night city it was like the reason to
stay it was judy's reason to stay and
then
i go i do the arasaka thing and then
judy's like
you've been different um it's time for
me to move on and i was like
whoa why is judy breaking up with me
like of all the things to happen in my
ending
that hurt the most i i mean i also
didn't understand the ending at all it
was like i don't know why i'm in space
i really thought that i was going to go
to the moon at some point and i was kind
of sad
like going through the game because they
talk about space a lot yeah then you go
to space and it's like i'm
i i was like is this a suicide mission
like what is this it's like you're
pulling a
heist on a casino in space which is
super cool and i would love to
would have loved to do that and then but
judy i was just like
really like i thought you were right or
died judy like i really like i
uh hello i don't know i guess it is
because it's like it's supposed to show
that your
quest was ult to become a night city
legend is ultimately gonna just leave
you
alone and sad but i didn't choose to be
a night city legend
i chose to save my life and then that's
the thing
like it just feels like there's stuff
missing
yeah so i've seen all the endings except
the secret ending that's currently what
i'm
progressing to do uh but there's so if
you do the opposite of what you
you guys did you let johnny take over
your body and you get
uh an interesting epilogue where johnny
i've seen i've seen this one too
you've seen it okay yeah but you get an
interesting epilogue where you're where
you're johnny and you
and you teach this kid how to like play
music and whatnot
and it's kind of cool but once again it
feels kind of hollow there's
the ending if you help hanukkah or asaka
and that ending to me felt like the most
cyberpunky because they're like
hey we can get rid of this but we're
gonna have to send you to
an orbital arasaka station where you're
going to get performed
wherever you're going to get an
operation to have that removed from your
head and it works except you're
not yourself and then you find out that
basically the chip in your head has
made it so uh saburo arasaka
can basically live in his son they
basically implanted his brain into his
sound which i thought was like a really
cool stuff that's really cool
that's super interesting uh and then the
final one which i thought was the most
satisfying
uh was the one where you joined the
nomads
and it's kind of a shame because the
game phrases that if you ask for the
nomads help they're probably gonna die
and that's not necessarily what happens
pan am lives and a couple other
important characters live
too um and basically the way that that
one dies though
yeah really took me
i figured they would die
didn't realize it'd be quite like that
yeah
uh but your judy will come with you
essentially
you'll leave night city and judy will
come with you and
it fits with judy's story about how she
doesn't really feel at home in night
city and how she wants to leave
so i guess like i i definitely get the
disappointment of that other ending
where judy breaks up with you but i
think they do establish
with her character that she doesn't want
to be in night city yeah so
to me she likes that ending yeah that
nomad ending like
felt like a new start from or like a
good ending for me and for judy because
she finally got to do
what she originally was gonna do with
evelyn leave night city and get out of
there
and there's like a really good exchange
between you and judy
and but but the only odd thing is that
the last scene is with you and pan am
which is clearly there because you
picked her route
um which i kind of felt a little felt a
little off maybe if i
was a male v and was uh and like
picked pan am then it would have made a
little bit more sense
but yeah i think overall like that pan
am ending is
my favorite for sure yeah it
it yes i mean it makes it makes more
sense like it feels more
um hole i mean olympic maybe
well no she's straight i was like maybe
we're in a throuple but
no that's not how it works um but i
still
wish that like the ending had had more
to say about the experience
that you've gone through with johnny
about like
like i was just i i ended the game and i
was like all right
so peace yeah i i felt
deflated at the end of it and i don't
know i'm not saying that because i feel
like every game needs to have a happy
happy ending
yeah everyone gets what they want i
totally appreciate it when a game
doesn't do that like i got the worst
ending in the witcher 3 and i was like
oh i messed up
but i feel like there was something very
hollow about that ending that the first
ending that i got so i actually did do
these the honestly the most satisfying
ending for me was the secret ending
which um we have a video yeah i won't i
won't spoil it for you because i think
it is really good because
the way that that ending and in all the
endings they have
the characters who you've interacted
with at the end during the credits ring
you
which again speaks to the fact that it's
like
none of this is in the game itself as
any part of a quest or any follow-up or
anything it's this
they're all contained at the very end in
the credits and of course
like i did like three ra three runs at
the end
um i didn't do the arasaka board meeting
one um
and i i can't bring myself to face adam
smasher again
no um because i did it like one after
one after the other after the other
but it felt like they were using those
credits
to tie up loose ends however i'm
assuming they didn't count for the fact
that the playstation 5 will
crash pretty much every time you hit
credits so half of them i didn't see
but the rest of them just kind of felt
like
papering over the cracks a bit which
was disappointing to me i think it was
cool to see how they reacted to that
final
like choices that you make but it didn't
feel like it was
in a particularly memorable and
meaningful way
yeah i mean to your point too i think
i mean you you invoke the witcher 3 so i
have to say you're all right i've opened
the door
uh one of the most powerful things about
the witcher 3 is how you don't really
have a choice
on how your game is going to end like
obviously you make choices that factor
into the ending you're going to get
but you're not greeted with like here's
your three options what do you want to
do
and that's what's going to happen
instead it feels a bit out of your
control even though
you have made decisions that have
influenced that and to me that
felt way more natural it felt way more
way more weightier right like it didn't
feel like i could just start saves
coming to see different endings it felt
like oh this is what i'm
going with because this is the these are
how i've been playing gear up this whole
time
it's a stronger narrative design totally
and it's something that i feel like
games used to do
choice-based games used to do like back
in the day be like all right good ending
bad ending now it's your time to pick
but
it's literally the difference between
mass effect 2 and mass effect 3
yes exactly and and that that's kind of
what cyberpunk felt like it was like
wait you you guys just did this
incredible way to end a lengthy rpg
but you just kind of went back on that
and did this sort of just pick your
ending
which i know to be fair like there are
decisions you have to make throughout
the game in order to get those endings
which is cool but like just to distill
it down like that i think was a little
a little disappointing for me personally
yeah
we've been talking for a long time so uh
let's go to
kind of closing comments um we
do know that the next gen like they're
working on these big
substantial patches for the game to fix
performance there's gonna be
free dlc coming there's gonna be next
gen upgrades
are you gonna go back to night city jake
i know you're playing again in a minute
but are you
was there enough there to love to return
later on yeah i'll be back i'm not super
interested in the next gen updates i'm
more interested in
the dlc and the quality of life stuff
they do change because i imagine it'll
be
a lot and that's something we saw in the
witcher 3 right they were adding new
features
new ui changes and whatnot like for
years after that game came out so i'm
super curious to see
what they do there
um i don't think so i i think i you know
like
i saw the things that i wanted to see um
i really you know have talked at length
about how i love judy as a character
and i i really like pan am and rogue and
um and johnny and
there's just a lot of stuff that i liked
there but um
i think like i i saw it and i got it and
you know night city is such an
unpleasant place to be that um
i i don't know barring substantial
changes
that would pique my interest i don't
know if i would really want to return
uh just in and just go through all of
the stuff i didn't like in order to see
those things again
yeah i totally understand it i think i
need
a lot more time away from it i
like i said i really enjoyed my time in
it despite the issues that i've had with
it and
and definitely on reflection when you're
talking about it with other people
you're like oh yeah that bit was
annoying
or like yeah i didn't like that so much
um but i think
there is enough there that i would
definitely want to go back and i
think i'm just going to hold off you
know regardless of the patches that are
going to come
i'm going to wait for a big substantial
thing like dlc
to draw me back in um because i think
i've seen a lot of the of the bad of it
and i don't want to be optimistic about
the good i think just quickly i think
dlc is going to be super interesting
because
the way that game is set up currently
dlc wouldn't make a lot of sense like i
don't know how you could
necessarily add davie's story without it
feeling even more like
a waste of time in v's overall narrative
that was a side tangent that i just
wanted to get in but i'm curious to see
what they do with dlc
definitely all right well thank you two
for joining me
and thank you all for watching if you
want to see more cyberpunk
we've got a lot of it here on the
channel we've got guides we've got
um what we want to see we've got updates
on everything going on with the game
so make sure to like this video and
subscribe for more uh you can find us
all on twitter cali
you can find me on twitter at inkydojico
i-n-k-y-d-o-j-i-k-k-o
jake you can find me at jacob deck
and i'm at lucy james games and we will
see you soon
you